merci ma question est à la ministre
d'affaires étrangères il y a quelques
jours 18 anciens ambassadeurs de France
ont appelé un rééquilibrage de notre
diplomatie au proche- Orient il déplore
que la seule réponse au massacre
injustifiable commis par le Hamas soit
une guerre totale un cauchemar
humanitaire des bombardements
indiscriminés et disproportionnés ayant
fait à Gaza 13000 morts civiles donc
5300 enfants il s'inquiète d'une
politique que le ministère français des
Affaires étrangères a lui-même qualifié
de terreur opéré par les colons si
Jordan occupé avec le soutien du
gouvernement israélien à Gaza la trêve
en cour prolongé de 48h à ce stade a
permis la libération d'otage nous
partageons notamment votre immense
soulagement après la libération de trois
otages mineurs
franco-israéliens mais c'est insuffisant
au regard de la souffrance des familles
cette rêve a également permis enfin la
livraison d'aide humanitaire mais c'est
insuffisant au regard des immenses
besoins le 9 novembre le président de la
République a appelé un cesser le feu la
ministre des Affaires
étrangères même dit dimanche la France
considère qu'il faut une trêve qui
permette d'aboutir à un cesser le feu
ces paroles sont bienvenues et pour
qu'elle soit entendue et suivie des
faits il faut des actes que fait la
France concrètement pour contribuer à ce
cesser le feu cette étape est décisive
car elle doit être la première vers une
solution politique sur la base du droit
international et en particulier d'une
solution à deux États qui quoi qu'en
disent les sceptiques n'a jamais été
tenté il faut que la diplomatie franç 16
soit au rendez-vous de son histoire et
de la
paix je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier bestch ministre en
charge du commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité des Français de
l'étranger merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Le Gal
permettez-moi à nouveau d'excuser
l'absence de la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères retenu à une
réunion ministérielle de l'OTAN
permettez-moi aussi de me réjouir
comme vous du retour de ces trois
enfants Herz SAR et etane néanmoins
notre joie est contenue puisque nous
pensons toujours aux C français qui sont
portés disparus et qui probablement sont
encore au Tage du Hamas et sachez que
nous ne ménageons aucun effort pour les
rendre à l'affection de leur famille la
France n'abandonne aucun de ses
concitoyens la position de la France
est constante elle n'a pas évolué depuis
quasiment les débuts de la 5e République
Monsieur le députés nous avons toujours
été favorable à une situation à deux
États qui est la seule qui permette à
deux peuples de vivre en paix et en
sécurité côte à côte nous ne ménangeons
pas les efforts de la diplomatie
française en ce moment même sur le
terrain pour faire en sorte que la trêve
humanitaire que nous appelons depuis des
semaines et qui a permis monsieur le
député la libération des otages que
cette trêve puisse être prolongé et que
cette trêve puisse déboucher sur un
cesser le feu qui lui-même permettra de
réengager le processus politique qui
permettra à deux états de vivre en paix
et en sécurité c'est tout le sens
monsieur le député de l'engagement de la
diplomatie
française je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député
je crains que cette voix ne soit pas
assez entendue car elle est pas suivie
d'acte fort et donc je rappelle que
j'appelle à à marcher pour la paix la
justice et à in cesser le feu permanent
à l'appel de nombreuses associations ONG
syndicat partis politique ce samedi à
14h merci je vous
remercie